c'est tout un spectacle comment faire le
président tchèque
la leader démocrate en chambre nancy
pelosi et le leader démocrate au sénat
cheechoo mme châtelain bureau ovale et
devant les caméras
les trois politiciens nous ont donné un
aperçu des tensions qui règnent sur la
question de la construction du mur si
chère au président d'un autre homme
menace de paralyser le gouvernement
si les démocrates refusent de financer
son mur à la frontière mexicaine wii de
nintendo wii just be good to green les
démocrates propose d'octroyer plus d'un
milliard de dollars pour la sécurité
comme l'année dernière mais le président
en réclame 5 milliard 26 pile aussi
hitcher schummer accuse d'un autre homme
de mentir au sujet du mur
selon le washington post trump à 10,86
fois en sept mois que sa construction
était commencée alors que le mur promis
n'est pas encore construit des marques
affirme nancy pelosi va nous offrir pour
noël
la paralysie du gouvernement un district
au terme à la crise dans fanfan du
président déclare tschopp chômeurs ne va
pas lui donner son mur
alors sorti de la maison blanche les
démocrates avaient obtenu ce qu'ils
souhaitaient entendre le président
assume et l'éventuelle paralysie du
gouvernement
les américains savent maintenant que
dans l'ancien est prête à tout pour
obtenir son mur même à paralyser le
fonctionnement de l'état ici christian
latreille radio-canada washington